DAVE MARKS: Welcome again.
My name's Dave Marks.
And today we'll be hearing
from Kira Asatryan.
Kira's a relationship
coach, author, blogger,
and loneliness expert.
She calls loneliness a problem
of epidemic proportions
in our modern times and
writes about this topic
for various online
blogs, including
"Time," "Psychology
Today," "Psych Central,"
and "Elite Daily."
She's spent her career
researching, pondering,
and reflecting upon
what specifically makes
relationships good or bad.
And now she's taken
all that knowledge
and published her first book,
"Stop Being Lonely-- Three
Simple Steps to Developing
Close Friendships and Deep
Relationships."
So we've been lucky to
get some subsidized copies
through Google [INAUDIBLE].
So please pick one up at the
back of the room before you
go, and I'm sure she'd be
happy to sign them for you,
if you can stick around for
a few minutes after the talk.
And so with that, I'd like
to introduce to you Kira.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Thank you
for coming, everyone.
Hello, everyone on the internet.
I don't have any
slides or anything.
I just am going to talk a little
bit, because I want everybody
who's listening to this to
kind of get the gist of what
"Stop Being Lonely" is about
even if you don't end up
reading it.
So I figured I'd
start by just talking
a little bit about how to
"Stop Being Lonely" came to be.
When I started writing
it, my only goal
was really to
write the book that
would have helped me in my own
social life about 10 years ago.
I'm 32 now, and my
loneliest period of my life
was in college, which felt very
weird and unusual at the time.
I found out now that it's
actually not that unusual.
But at the time, I
really would have
liked to have had a book
like "Stop Being Lonely."
I have really dealt with
loneliness my whole life.
I felt it for as long as
I can remember, really.
And I would also
say that it's fair
that I've dealt with my own
fair share of shyness and social
anxiety, which, of course,
can co-occur with loneliness.
But the issue for
me was not really
that I was afraid to
interact with people,
which is kind of the
hallmark of social anxiety.
Most of the feedback that I
got from people was positive.
Most people thought I was
generally nice and sweet.
So I didn't really
avoid people because I
feared their judgment.
I avoided people
because I didn't really
enjoy interacting with them
that much, at least not as much
as everyone else seemed to.
And this really
bothered me because I
would tend to isolate
myself, and then I
would become extremely
lonely when I was alone.
And I thought, what
was wrong with me?
Part of what compounded
my frustration
with my own loneliness
was that there
wasn't a terribly good
reason for me to be lonely.
I have a really nice family.
In high school, I had people
I could sit with at lunch.
And as an adult, I had
boyfriends and acquaintances,
and I just thought, shouldn't
these relationships be enough?
But no matter how
many people I could
put on my objective list
of people in my life,
the same thing always
really bothered me;
I didn't know what
it was that made
some relationships feel good
and others feel not so good.
I didn't understand why
some of my interactions
with some people were loneliness
remedies, while others felt
like loneliness intensifiers.
I really wanted to understand
the root cause of what
made me feel close
to certain people
and not close to other people.
This was really the
central issue for me.
Because not knowing what caused
that feeling of closeness,
made every interaction
with every person
feel risky, something
to be avoided.
So in 2013, I left
my very techie job--
I was a performance
marketer and I did growth
at various Facebook
app companies.
I ran Facebook
ads-- in an attempt
to sort of answer some of
these questions for myself,
and I became a relationship
coach and mediator.
I spent the first
two years of those
roughly three years that it's
been researching the science
of intimate relationships.
And I can summarize
what science has
to say about relationships in
two words; they're complicated.
And what I mean by
that is this; science
has pinpointed tons and
tons and tons of things
that you're supposed to do
to have a good relationship
with someone.
You're supposed to show empathy.
You're supposed
to self-disclose,
meaning talk about
yourself, but not too much.
You're supposed to offer
practical assistance,
but not right away.
You're supposed to develop
interdependence, but not
prematurely-- that's bad--
and so on and so forth.
And while it all
kind of made sense
to me, my next thought
was, can anybody really
do all of this stuff?
To me, this laundry list of
things you're supposed to have
and things you're supposed to
do in relationships, things
you're supposed to have,
like trust, communication,
et cetera, et cetera, just
seemed really, really complex
to put into practice.
And in real life
interactions, especially
if you have any amount
of social anxiety,
it's extremely hard
to recall complexities
around what you are
and are not supposed
to do around other people,
or what you are and are not
supposed to say to people.
In fact, in my own experience,
convoluted do-this,
don't-do-that advice make
social anxiety worse.
So I asked myself, is there
any way to make this simple?
Is there a way to streamline
what real research says
about relationships
and sum it all up
in some kind of practical way?
I sat with this question
for a long time.
And then the answer
just kind of came to me,
as answers sometimes do.
And the answer to me it was
this; knowing plus caring
equals closeness.
Closeness, which is the real
focus of "Stop Being Lonely,"
is that thing that makes
some relationships feel
good and others not feel good.
It's the ingredient that
makes the difference
between an interaction from
which you walk away feeling
more lonely or less lonely.
It is, really, for all
intents and purposes,
the antidote to loneliness.
And it's created through
just two things--
knowing and carrying.
All of those
scientifically proven bits
of good relationship
stuff can pretty elegantly
fit into these two categories.
And what I like about
this formula, so to speak,
is that it's very
easy to remember.
All you really have to
do in a social situation
is ask yourself,
should I be trying
to know this person
or care about them?
So before I dive into
what that really means
and what it looks
like in real life,
I want to circle back to
loneliness for a second,
because loneliness these
days is really, really weird.
In another time and place,
you would not really
feel that lonely, unless
you did something wrong
or for some reason were
shunned by your people.
But today loneliness
is extremely
frustrating and confusing
for many people.
And the first thing that's
become abundantly clear to me
through my work and
my own life experience
is that modern day
loneliness is not
caused by a lack of
people in one's life.
Now, of course, literal
social isolation can cause,
loneliness and social
isolation comes
with its own list of issues.
If you live out in a cabin
somewhere by yourself
or you live in a very sparsely
populated town or something
like that, loneliness
is going to be something
that comes along with that.
But there are a
plethora of studies
that show that one person
can be physically alone,
even for a pretty long
time, and feel totally fine.
While another person can
have hundreds of friends
and feel desperately lonely.
So if loneliness and aloneness
are not the same thing, then
what is loneliness?
Well, first, it's a feeling.
It's not an objective state
of being, like aloneness is.
And it's actually a feeling
that's kind of hard to define.
Science has a lot of different
definitions for what loneliness
actually is, and when
it comes down to it,
it's kind of just one of those
you-feel-it-when-you-feel-it
feelings.
So, for a moment, I want to
take myself back to high school.
As I mentioned earlier, I had
people to sit with at lunch,
and I was invited by fair
share of social activities
in high school.
And if somebody had
asked my teachers,
does Kira have friends?
They would have said,
yes, she has friends.
But, one day, when I
was in the ninth grade,
I had a freak
accident with a horse,
and I broke my shoulder
and arm into 16 pieces,
and I had to have a surgery
that's only ever performed
on adult male rugby players.
In fact, my surgeon had to
delay the surgery for a week
so that he could go
learn how to do it.
So it was kind of scary
stuff for a 13-year-old.
And to my anguish, it seemed
to me that none of my friends
really cared.
Of course they noticed that
I was gone for a while.
But once the story of what
had happened circulated,
it seemed to me that their
curiosity was quenched.
They figured they'd talk to me
about it when they got back,
and they knew I
was basically OK.
But the lack of seeming
concern broke my heart.
It was then that I felt the
distinction between having
friends and feeling close.
And in our modern world, I
think that this distinction
between literal
aloneness, or having
no friends, and the subjective
feeling of loneliness
is becoming ever more obvious.
Everyone has Facebook friends.
Everyone has a phone
full of contacts
that they could
theoretically contact
about anything at any time.
But do we actually do this?
And does it really matter?
Personal technology,
specifically
the internet and mobile
phones, has made it
so that we have people available
to us all the time, at least
in theory.
We never really need to
lose contact with someone.
And if we do,
technology makes it
so that we can meet someone new.
In many ways, we have
less literal aloneness
than any other
people have ever had.
And yet, despite this
forever connectedness,
levels of loneliness
are rising across
the entire Western world.
At any given moment,
one in five Americans,
that's 60 million people,
is feeling lonely.
And that's up at least 30%
since the '80s-- at least 30%.
So what does that mean?
I see these two
things taken together,
that we have less aloneness,
yet more loneliness,
to mean that it's not
experiencially enough to have
people around you.
And the goal should
not be to have
more contacts in your phone or
more social media connections.
The goal should be to replace
the negative experience
of loneliness with the
very positive experience
of closeness.
Or to put it another way, it's
about quality, not quantity.
How one perceives the quality
of one's relationships
is vastly more important than
the number of relationships
that one has.
And to really feel the
difference between quality
and quantity, I want to do
a tiny little visualization,
because I'm a coach, and
we do stuff like this.
So close your eyes for a second.
Imagine that you're eating
a piece of stale bread.
Now imagine that you're eating
the most delicious meal you've
ever eaten.
Do you feel the difference?
OK, you can open your eyes.
My point is that the difference
is not a functional difference.
Both stale bread and a delicious
meal satisfy real hunger.
The difference is qualitative.
The differences in
the amount of pleasure
you derive from the experience.
In my opinion,
when we're lonely,
we're not starving
for human interaction
and just ready to take
anything we can get.
We're hungry for a certain
pleasurable experience.
We're hungry for a
little bit of closeness.
So let's talk about
closeness and how
to create it in your life.
The word closeness has a
lot of different definitions
in the social sciences.
But, in my world, it has a
very specific definition.
It means the experience
of having direct access
to another person's inner
world, to her dreams, her fears,
her habits, her
preferences, et cetera.
Once you have direct access to
another person's inner world,
you can sit next to her and
know what she's thinking.
You can look into her eyes
and feel what she's feeling.
And as I've said,
this is created
through knowing and caring.
Knowing, as I define
it, means being
able to see someone's life
from their own perspective.
And caring means expressing
interest and investment
in that person's well-being.
So let's talk a
little about knowing.
Knowing, in the
sense that I use it,
is actually pretty different
from how we usually
know people.
We tend to think we
know someone when
we've interacted with
them a lot and developed
a theory of how they are.
My cousin Lisa is
a total pushover.
My old boss had anger issues.
My best friend is the most
dependable person in the world.
While these things
may be true for me,
as you can probably
see, they are
evaluations that I have
made of this other person.
They're my perceptions.
Take the last example
of my best friend.
I may experience her
as being dependable.
But from her
perspective, she may
experience her own
dependability as anxiety
about not wanting
to let anybody down.
Until I understand
her experience
of her own dependability
from her perspective,
I don't really know
her and a way that
makes her feel close to me.
In the same way, the
way that I define caring
is kind of different
than how we usually
try to care about people.
In our culture, we
usually show caring
by either worrying about someone
or trying to give them advice.
And, unfortunately, neither
one of these mechanics
work that well for
creating closeness.
Giving advice, which is usually
really well-intentioned,
doesn't work that well
because it actually places you
in a superior position,
as the one who
knows things or the
one who can fix things
for the other person,
which actually kind
of seeds resentment in them.
Expressing concern
through worrying
doesn't really work
that well either
because it prompts
the other person
to try to prove that
everything is OK with them
to ease your discomfort.
Instead, the kind of
caring that I talk about
is just the act of
simply expressing
interest and an investment in
the other person's well-being,
and it opens the door
for emotional connection.
It says to the other
person, I'm here.
I'm listening to you.
What would you like to say?
Together, knowing
and caring work well
because they are a
powerful combination.
They communicate not
only do I really see you,
I'm listening to you.
Not only do I understand
you, I also value you.
So have you ever had
that experience where
you learn a new
word and then you
start hearing it everywhere?
That's kind of what happened
to me after I came up
with this knowing plus caring
equals closeness thing.
I started seeing it pop
up all over the place
in the unconscious phrasing
of some of the most
famous relationship experts.
Is anybody here familiar with
the "Five Love Languages?"
It's like the most famous
love book out there.
In it, Gary Chapman says,
"with verbal encouragement,
we are trying to
communicate 'I know.
I care.
How can I help?'"
Psychologist, researcher,
and bestselling
author John Gottman,
and he's also my personal crush,
ends in anecdote from his book
"What Makes Love
Last" by saying,
"a husband I once helped came
to accept that he could not
control what his wife feels,
and that it's not his job to get
her to cheer up, calm down,
or develop a sense of humor.
All she needs is for him
to know her and care."
The type of loneliness
that most of us
are experiencing these
days is fundamentally
an internal loneliness,
a loneliness
of the heart and mind.
Knowing someone well and
caring about them deeply
creates a mental and emotional
closeness, or a closeness
of the heart and mind.
And by eliminating
this internal distance,
closeness eliminates the sadness
that comes with it, also known
as loneliness.
In this way, closeness
acts as the opposite
of loneliness and the
antidote to its effects.
So to wrap things up, just one
more thing-- and this thing
is important;
closeness is something
that is within your
control to create
with anyone who also wants it.
So it really is something
that you can start having now.
So what could you do to start
feeling less lonely right now?
So I will save you any
icebreakers or friendship
pick-up lines, which
sometimes people ask me for,
and instead just
talk about something
quickly from the book.
It's an idea called "separate
the person from the problem."
And I didn't come up with it;
it's from business negotiation.
The premise of separate
the person from the problem
is that to maintain
positive relationships
during hard times, one must
think of people and problems
as separate entities.
In other words, it's
easier to come up
with a resolution with someone
when you don't view them
as the problem.
Once you make this
distinction, you
can treat the person
with love and respect
and thoroughly
eliminate the problem.
So one thing you
can do right now
to start feeling less lonely
is to start separating yourself
from the problem of loneliness.
You are really not to blame
if you're feeling lonely.
You are a precious
person who is deserving
of love and closeness,
and loneliness
is a problem outside of you that
can be thoroughly eliminated.
And that's all I have.
DAVE MARKS: So those of you
who haven't read the book yet,
"Stop Being Lonely," it's great.
Kira only talked about
just a small portion
of what she goes into n there.
And I really like how, at
the end of each chapter,
you give really practical
tips that people
can start employing
today, even how
to break down it down
into littler steps,
because it's a
little overwhelming.
KIRA ASATRYAN: It's a lot.
I can be a lot, yeah.
DAVE MARKS: So I guess
my first question to you
is the role technology plays.
I think you emphasize
a lot in your book
that modern-day technology
and it's efficiencies
gives us a little bit
of technology brain
and makes us all less
comfortable with like wasting
time or inefficient steps.
I definitely feel that
in like new friendships
or potentially dating, that
unless I'm really into it,
or I think it has a great
chance of panning out,
I'm scared to use my limited
time and energy on that.
How do recommend people
with the technology brain
find the balance,
and you balance
between getting
out there and not
wasting our time and energy,
overcoming that fear?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Yeah, so the
thing that you're referencing
is that I talk about how
the more that we interact
with our devices, that are
designed to be supremely
efficient, it's kind of
like the less patience
you have for real-life
interactions with real people.
And I would say the
first step is just kind
of understanding that idea.
So developing awareness
that like, OK,
I might be being a little
impatient right now,
or I am not getting the
results that I expected,
so I don't want to do it.
It's kind of a results-oriented
mentality that a lot of people
are developing.
But human relationships
are just not that clean.
Yeah, so that would
be the first thing--
develop awareness about it.
And then kind of go with it?
Meaning, hold the
outcome more loosely.
Because especially dating--
dating's a great example.
If you go into thinking I
understand who this person is
and this is what I
want out of this date,
you are probably going
to be disappointed.
DAVE MARKS: Right, so
be a little bit more
patient and less focused
on a specific outcome?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Right.
DAVE MARKS: Take it as
it comes-- I like that.
I'd like to [INAUDIBLE],
if anyone would like
to pop up and ask a question?
AUDIENCE: Just
wondering, how can you
tell if someone is lonely,
if the facade of them
doesn't seems to be lonely?
KIRA ASATRYAN: How can you tell
that someone else is lonely?
AUDIENCE: That's right.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Oh, I don't
know if thought about that.
AUDIENCE: More specifically,
a 12-year-old, my daughter.
KIRA ASATRYAN: So I was doing
another talk the other day,
and we were starting to
talk about teenagers.
And they are lonely.
One of the big spikes that we
see in sort of demographics
is 15 to 22.
So she's a little
younger than that,
but they are having
issues with this.
I think that the-- this is
sort of just my speculation.
But I think what's going
on with a lot of people
of that age is that
they've grown up
with this kind of public life.
Like a lot of them have a public
persona that they develop,
which is really weird for a
young teenager to have that.
And so they become
fiercely protective
of their private
lives, so much so,
that I think they
might be having
a little bit of a hard time
getting to know each other.
Because the average
15-year-old or 12-year-old
is just very, very private.
So how can you tell
if they're lonely?
I mean I would just trying
to be present with her.
And if there are moments
when she starts to open up,
like be available for it.
But it's kind of a hard
situation in that age range.
DAVE MARKS: Kira, in
reference to that,
I thought one of the
best parts of your book
was about asking
open-ended questions.
Could you maybe pitch
an open-ended question
you could ask to someone to
get to know them a little bit
or maybe get them to open
up about their potential
loneliness?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Mm hm.
Oh, yeah, there's lots of them.
Well, my favorite one that
I talk about in the book,
because it's just my favorite,
is, what does that get you?
And you can ask it kind
of in any situation.
But what it's for
is like let's say
that somebody is thinking
of changing careers.
What does that you?
Or they're thinking
of buying a house.
What does that get you?
And the purpose of the
open-ended question
is to go from this kind of
surface layer that a lot of us
talk on about like what we're
doing, what we're working on.
What's going on and
go one layer deeper
into what we're
hoping to achieve
or what's motivating
these decisions.
Or just what are you
trying to get out
of what you're doing
with your life,
because that's really
who the person is.
You know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: There
was an interesting
you said sort of near the end.
It was, if I captured
it right, closeness
is within your control to create
with anyone else who wants it,
and that part really struck me.
So it's another question sort of
about how you read someone else
and get a sense of who people,
who are ready and actually
interested in real
closeness and those
who may not be ready for it?
KIRA ASATRYAN: That's
a great question.
That's an excellent question.
My first thing I would say is
you're going to know instantly.
But you can know within, I would
say, one or two interaction
with them, like
real interactions,
like a one-on-one coffee
date or something.
You could tell if somebody
is a good, what I call,
"closeness partner."
And the way that
you vet that out
is, do they have the
basic skills to do
knowing and caring?
And so on the knowing
side it would be,
are they willing to reveal
anything about themselves?
And are they
interested in getting
to know anything about you?
So if somebody is
feeling very-- people who
feel very vulnerable
in situations
tend to keep everything
to themselves.
That person might not be
great at this type of stuff.
And then on the caring side,
it's about emotional capacity.
So does it seem like they
can empathize with you?
Do they use a feeling
language for anything?
Like, I love my job.
I can't wait to see my mom.
I like her so much-- whatever.
Like do they show emotional
capacity in any way?
Those would be the two things.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Sure.
DAVE MARKS: In
your book you say,
"my favorite social
experiment in learning
to pick partners can be found
on your TV Monday night's
at 8:00 PM.
It's called "The Bachelor."
And you go on to say
like, "The Bachelor" isn't
the best at making
marriages; but it
is really good at this one
thing of making people feel
like they're falling in love.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Yeah, it's
fascinating stuff to me.
I also talk about
Kim Kardashian.
There's some stuff
in there like that.
DAVE MARKS: And so
what are the, other
than like awesome
free dates, what
are the environments that create
the feeling of falling in love?
And is there
anything we can take
that to apply to
our personal lives
to perhaps really use
those to fall in love?
KIRA ASATRYAN:
Well, the big thing
that I think "The Bachelor"
gets right is that people
are going there with
the intention to get
to know the people there.
It's a fascinating
experiment for me,
because they're encouraged
to get to know each other
and develop caring
for one another,
but they can't go
straight to the end.
Like they can't get
married on the first show;
they're actually not
allowed to do that.
So it's this kind
of like paced thing
that actually works pretty well.
Like most of them develop a lot
of closeness with each other,
and least the last couple
contestants at the end
feel very, very close to the
bachelor and the bachelorette.
DAVE MARKS: And so you say
the number one thing that
causes that is the intention.
They come in with the
intention of getting close.
So we need to find people
that want to get close to us,
I guess, right?
What are some signs you might
be able to look for, I guess?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Of somebody
who wants to get close to you?
DAVE MARKS: Yeah.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Well, if you're
in certain environments,
opportunities will kind
of present themselves.
Like I think Google is
actually a good example.
If you work at Google,
there's probably
people around you who would
be interested in being
closer to you.
If you're very, very isolated,
that's more difficult.
But I would say
anybody who approaches
you to talk about
anything outside of work
is probably
interested in getting
to know you as a person.
AUDIENCE: I have one, actually.
I don't know if I can
articulate very well,
so you'll have to bear with me.
The gentleman who asked about
his daughter actually kind of
gave me a vehicle to
ask this question.
So you mentioned quality
over quantity, right?
So let's extrapolate
that for a moment.
So we have 1,000
Facebook friends.
That's quantity.
But if we can five or
10 friends with whom
we have that intimacy,
that caring you describe,
we're probably doing better.
If we take that further
though, because I
will attest to that
maybe on a Friday,
going out with a
very good friend
and having like a nice
conversation with them
and feeling cared for,
but still [INAUDIBLE]
go home and still a little empty
even after that interaction.
If you can have even one friend
who really kind of gets you,
that can be kind of cool.
So where I'm going with
this is that friend
might be you perhaps.
And the reason is, you mentioned
the public persona, right?
12- to 22-year-olds,
probably more so
than any other
demographic, probably
know themselves the least
and are figuring it out.
So is some of it maybe
not on us, in a way,
to really accept who we are, and
have intimacy with ourselves?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Totally, that's a
really good question, because I
actually, in the first
draft of this book,
I didn't have
anything about that,
about getting
closer to yourself.
And my editor was
like, you're kind
of expecting that people
have done a lot of self-work
already, and she was right.
I was kind of assuming that.
So there is a
chapter in there now
about having do knowing
and caring with yourself.
Self-care is actually
a big thing right now.
Like if you're in
the self-help world,
self-care is like a very
trendy thing right now.
But it's real.
It works.
Making time for
yourself and doing
the things that
kind of replenish
you are pretty important,
and getting to know yourself,
of course-- you're own needs
and values and motivation.
AUDIENCE: Very cool.
Thank you for that, yeah.
DAVE MARKS: I was going to say,
I identify as an introvert,
right?
And I very much so
like enjoy getting
to know myself and like
thinking through my emotions
and feelings.
And sometimes it's
super energizing.
But I notice that it
hits this point where
it becomes pretty isolating.
Do you have any vision on how we
can balance it better or flags
we can look for in ourselves
to know when we are recharging
versus going into a lonely hole?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Yeah,
there is a version
of isolating yourself or being
alone that's really positive.
It's like solitude.
And I'm totally
an introvert too.
And I think that my
introvertedness seeps through
into the book.
It kind of has that
perspective that
assumes that sometimes
people like to be alone.
But, like I said, the
loneliness-versus-closeness
thing is really,
really subjective.
So if you kind of
are keeping tabs
on how your aloneness
is making you feel,
you can probably identify when
that switch starts to happen.
The thing about loneliness
is that it's really bad
when you feel like
you can't stop it,
like when you feel
like, OK, I am
aware that it's switched over
into this feeling bad thing.
But I don't know what to do.
So that was the issue that
I was trying to speak to.
DAVE MARKS: So it's all
new tools to get out of it.
Once you notice it,
you'll be all right.
A lot of times people ask me
like, are you a people person?
And my response is, I like
to be alone until I'm lonely.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Right, exactly.
DAVE MARKS: That's how its.
AUDIENCE: So,
multi-part question,
all related to my
12-year-old daughter.
I could probably ask you
a lot more afterwards.
But you mentioned that you felt
lonely when you were 13, right?
Is there a section in your book
which talks a little bit more
about your background
at 13 years old
and your state of mind?
And so that's one part.
The other part is, is this book
suitable for a 12-year-old?
Like if give this to my daughter
to read, is it suitable?
And the last part
associated with that
is, what do I say if I
give her this book to read?
You know, I attended
this talk at Google.
I thought it was fascinating.
Here's a great book.
I'm almost saying, I
think you're lonely.
But she might not feel lonely.
Sorry.
DAVE MARKS: So I'm not
sure that one got caught,
but just to reiterate.
So as for your teenage
daughter, right,
would this book be
appropriate for her?
And if you were to get it for
her, what would be a good way
to present it to her,
rather than being like,
I think you'd like this?
KIRA ASATRYAN: I know,
it's an aggressive title.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, very aggressive.
KIRA ASATRYAN: It is.
I fought for it.
I like the title.
But, yeah, it is.
I'm going to do your
second question first.
Yes, I think it would
be appropriate for her.
It's about all relationships
not romantic or dating.
It applies to family
relationships and friends.
So, yeah, I think
it's appropriate.
I would probably present
it as like this is just
a look about relationships or
how to-- I haven't interacted
with a lot of 12-year-olds.
But try to make it more
about just like here's
a book about like social
skills or something,
than about loneliness,
because that
might be insulting eventually.
AUDIENCE: Exactly,
yeah, insulting.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Yeah, it can be.
And I forgot your
first question.
What was the first one?
AUDIENCE: Oh, because you
wrote the book about yourself,
do you cover how your state
of mind was at 13-years-old?
KIRA ASATRYAN: I didn't.
I only actually talk
about my own story
at the very, very end, and
it's about being as an adult.
But I can talk about it now.
I thought I was depressed
because lonely wasn't really
a thing in my mind.
And I kind of think that there
is quite a number of people
who think they're
depressed, when really it's
about this issue more
than anything else.
But I don't know;
I was a good kid,
so I just kept going with it.
And then eventually
I was old enough
to know that it probably
wasn't really my fault. Like,
I was being nice to people.
DAVE MARKS: I'll come at
it, if you don't mind,
because I was a
super angsty teen.
And the number one thing I
felt was misunderstood, right?
And I think it was very much
so because I was changing
every day, and I had
a really hard time
getting to know myself.
And so I constantly
felt misunderstood
by everyone around me.
Because even they understood
who I was yesterday,
that's who I am today anymore,
because I'm changing a lot.
And I'm becoming a
grown man and all this.
And that's what it was.
And then when I finally
got to a more state
where I'm like, oh,
OK, this is who I am,
I started being able to
share that with people more.
Then they could
actually understand me.
I would say that's the
number one adjective
I felt in my teenage years.
AUDIENCE: I loved
how you called out
that focusing on the number
of friends or social media
contacts doesn't necessarily
get you where you want it,
that it's almost a fallacy
to look for closeness just
by quantity.
Another thought that I had
was, you mentioned, Dave,
just now being misunderstood.
I feel like part of the problem
sometimes with loneliness
is you just don't feel
like there's people who
get you or can relate to you.
Everybody has their
own flavor of that.
From me, I went to a very
broadly Caucasian Catholic high
school.
And I come from this Buddhist
family that's vegetarian
and doesn't drink.
And so throughout
college, especially,
you mentioned feeling
lonely in college,
everybody's a at the frat
house, and I'm the only one,
and nobody really gets me.
Now, I thought
it, and I might be
wrong in this, is that if
I just find people like me,
that intimacy will be there.
But I look around today at my
closest friends, the ones who
we totally get each other;
they're not necessarily
of the same background as me,
but we have that closeness.
So do you have to find people
who are really just like you?
KIRA ASATRYAN: No, you do not.
In the studies that have been
done, like official research
social science studies,
it tends to pan out
that people who are
more like each other
do like each other more.
But also, it's a
self-reported thing.
So they may sort of
be-- the way that it
being like each other
helps is that you
don't have to do quite as much
work in the knowing department.
Like you can just say, I'm
Buddhist, and I'm vegetarian.
And somebody who
else is like that
will make that
connection instantly.
So there's a little
less heavy lifting.
But it can be done with anybody
who's willing to open up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVE MARKS: I'd like to stay
on friendship for a little bit.
You just mentioned offhand
that people ask you
for friendship pick-up lines.
Do you have one you're
like willing to share?
And, B, I feel
like I moved here,
that I didn't know anyone.
And I went through
this period where I
felt like I was dating friends.
Do you know what I mean?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Totally.
DAVE MARKS: I'd like you
talk about that experience
and your thoughts on that.
KIRA ASATRYAN: I think San
Francisco is like a hub of that
because so many people
are transplants.
I actually grew up
here, so I did not
have that exact experience.
But, yeah, my advice
on that kind of thing
is if you can tolerate
it, start out in groups.
Meaning like go to
something that's
like an interest-based group
or something like that.
But go there seeking somebody
who you would want to hang out
with outside of the interest.
So meaning like, let's say
you like rock climbing.
A way to meet people is
to go to a rock climbing
club or something.
But then try to
identify somebody
who you want to hang out
with not rock climbing.
And then those will end
up being your people.
DAVE MARKS: That's really
good, tangible advice.
I think the book is full
of good, tangible things
like that.
KIRA ASATRYAN: I'm trying.
DAVE MARKS: Yeah.
It's hard today.
How do I make a friend?
KIRA ASATRYAN: The hardest ones
are the love ones, the love
question, because who knows?
How do people fall in love?
I don't know.
DAVE MARKS: Been working on it.
So I guess back to
love relationships,
you wrote an article
online last week
that said that single men are
way lonelier than single women,
which I agree.
But it's just that single
women are like a little more
ready to admit it.
So I feel like a lot
of men-- and I've
seen this with most my
friends and peers-- feel
they need to take on like the
lone-wolf mentality, like I
like being alone, even
though they don't like it.
I don't want to do it.
Why do you think men
feel the need to do that?
And how can I, as like
a somewhat emotionally
available man,
help my friend feel
like it's OK to be lonely then?
KIRA ASATRYAN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think a lot of
it is conditioning.
I think that some of it is
the way that were raised.
But this is a fascinating
question for me
because I thought that the
whole knowing plus caring
equal closeness thing I thought
it was very gender-neutral.
But the more I talked to
men, they've been like,
this isn't really like how
men get close to people,
or it's not really
realistic or something.
And I didn't get it.
But I've been
starting to get it.
And I think that
this not wanting
to show any problems
in your social life
is a big, big part of
it and just the way
that men are taught to be.
DAVE MARKS: Do you think
it's legitimate that they
say this won't work for men?
Or men have been conditioned
to make it not work for them?
For me, I related
to it very much.
I thought it was a good formula.
Like you know someone.
You care about them.
You'll become close to them.
I thought it made
perfect sense and aligned
with a lot of experiences
I've seen in my real life.
KIRA ASATRYAN: I
think that for guys--
so the book basically takes
the romantic component out
of it, because then it was
going to be about intimacy,
and then it couldn't
apply really
to friendships and family
in the same kind of way.
And I don't want to go there.
But I think that the
intimacy, meaning
like romantic types
of relationships,
I think that men are more--
they need that a little bit more
than women do.
Like totally not romantic female
friendships are very common,
and they're quite a bit more
easy for women to develop.
And I think it's how we're
socialized, personally.
Eons of women have been
sitting around weaving,
talking to each other
and becoming friends.
But for men, it's been
a little bit different.
And our brains are ancient.
DAVE MARKS: There's a
lot of studies out there
that say a majority of men lose
a lot of their close friends
in their 20s because they
don't know how to keep them.
KIRA ASATRYAN: They
do, and there's
this idea of
closeness in the doing
is what it's called in the
social sciences, where men
think that they stay
close to each other
by doing things together.
And they kind of don't.
Like they think
if they go golfing
with their friend for
20 years that they know
stuff about them.
And then at the end of those
20 years, they're like,
I don't really know
that guy at all.
We're just friends.
DAVE MARKS: So I think we
have time for about one more.
I'd like to offer it to
someone in the audience, who'd
like to finish those off.
But if not, I have one
we can close out on.
All right, so it's Friday.
It's national Unplugging Day.
KIRA ASATRYAN: Oh,
yeah, that's right.
DAVE MARKS: And so I
assume a lot of people
will be going out and doing
social things tonight.
You said something in the book
that I identify with very much.
You say, "I found mediocre
social interactions only made
me more lonely," right?
And I agree with that very much.
You think like going out
and being with friends will
make you feel good.
And then you go home, and
you just feel more alone
than before it started.
Do you have any
recommendations of how
we can take mediocre
social interactions
to closer social interactions?
You know, if you're
at this party,
maybe there's
nonsense small talk,
or you feel like you don't
connect with any of the people,
how can we change that?
KIRA ASATRYAN: I'm going to
say something a little fruity
because I feel like it.
I think the one thing
you can really do
is be a little braver,
be a little bit bolder.
Because the people
that tend to--
and this is a generalization.
But the people that
tend to feel that way,
are the more timid people in
social interactions, especially
groups.
So ask a question that you
think might be a little too
personal, because
probably they won't mind.
It's much more likely that they
won't mind than that they'll
be offended or something.
That's my advice.
DAVE MARKS: I like it a lot.
So the book's "Stop Being
Lonely," Kira Asatryan,
available at the back for $10.
Kira, thank you so
much for coming.
We really appreciate it.